deficiência de vitaminas A vitamina B1
tiamina é uma grande aliada contra o
cansaço mas não para por aí a
deficiência de outras vitaminas e
minerais como é o caso da B12 e o ferro
também pode estar por trás dessa
exaustão Implacável e tem mais a falta
de potássio pode afetar as suas células
Pois todas elas contam com uma bomba de
sódio potássio que produz energia
elétrica Mas fique tranquilo há uma
abundância desse mineral potássio
disponível em diversas saladas
irresistíveis vegetais deliciosos e
frutas suculentas agora e o magnésio
esse mineral é essencial para produção
de energia no corpo e também pode ser
encontrado em grandes quantidades nas
saladas por isso investir uma dieta
balanceada e saborosa é fundamental para
combater a fadiga